Je savais quelque chose qu'elle ne savait pas.
Je savais que si dans une heure,
notre enfant n'était pas arrivé,
j'allais la laisser là
pour retourner au travail
et faire mon exposé sur l'IA
à mon chef, le PDG d'Apple.
Heureusement, ma fille est née à 11h30.
(Rire)
(Applaudissements)
M'évitant de commettre l'irréparable,
et aujourd'hui, je me sens toujours penaud
d'avoir laissé ma conscience professionnelle prendre le pas
sur l'amour de ma famille.
(Applaudissements)
Ma présentation sur IA, toutefois, s'est fort bien déroulée.
(Rires)
Apple a aimé mon travail et a décidé de le communiquer
lors de TED 1992,
il y a 26 ans, sur cette même estrade.
Je croyais avoir fait une de plus grandes et importantes découvertes sur l'IA,
tout comme le Wall Street Journal qui le publia le lendemain.
Mais aussi importante que cette découverte fut,
il s'est avéré que je n'avais découvert ni l'Inde, ni l'Amérique,
mais peut être une petite île au large du Portugal.
Mais le temps des découvertes continuait pour l'IA,
et toujours plus de scientifiques s'y consacraient.
Il y a 10 ans, la grande découverte sur l'IA
a été faite par trois chercheurs américains.
C'est l'apprentissage profond, ou « Deep Learning. »
Le « Deep Learning » est une technologie qui avale une grande quantité de données
sur un seul domaine
et apprend à faire des prédictions avec une exactitude surhumaine.
Par exemple, si on montre à ce réseau de neurones
une énorme quantité de photos de nourritures
il pourra reconnaître les aliments
pour les classer en « hot dog » ou « pas hot dog. »
(Applaudissements)
Ou si on lui donne pleins d'images, de vidéos et de données de capteurs
récoltées en conduisant sur la voie rapide,
il va véritablement savoir conduire une voiture aussi bien qu'un humain
sur la voie rapide.
Et que se passerait-il si on montrait à ce réseau d'apprentissage profond
tous les discours fait par le président Trump ?
Alors, ce président Trump artificiellement intelligent,
en fait, le réseau,
(Rires)
pourrait...
(Applaudissements)
Vous aimez les doubles oxymores, non ?
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Donc ce réseau, si on lui demande de faire un discours sur l'IA
il pourrait dire...
(Enregistrement) Donald Trump : « C'est super
de bâtir un monde meilleur avec l'intelligence artificielle. »
Kai-Fu-Lee : Et dans une autre langue ?
DT: (parle en chinois)
(Rires)
KFL: Vous ne saviez pas qu'il parlait chinois ?
Donc, l'apprentissage profond est au centre des découvertes sur l'IA,
et les USA sont à la pointe.
Mais nous sommes désormais dans l'étape de mise en œuvre,
et l'important c'est l'exécution, la qualité, la vitesse et les données.
Et c'est ici qu'intervient la Chine.
Les entrepreneurs chinois
que je finance en tant que capital-risqueur,
sont de travailleurs exceptionnels,
d'une conscience professionnelle hallucinante.
Mon exemple dans la salle d'accouchement,
n'est rien comparé aux travailleurs chinois.
Par exemple, une startup a un slogan sur l'équilibre travail/vie personnelle
« Rejoignez nous, car on fait du 996. »
Qu'est ce que ça veut dire ?
Ça veut dire travailler de 9h du matin à 9h du soir, six jours par semaine.
À relativiser avec les autres startups qui font du 997.
La qualité des produits chinois n'a pas cessé d'augmenter
durant la dernière décennie,
et cela grâce au milieu hyper concurrentiel.
Dans la Silicon Valley, les entrepreneurs rivalisent d'une façon très fair play,
un peu comme dans ces guerres antiques, dans lesquelles chaque côté
se tirait dessus à tour de rôle.
(Rires)
Mais dans le milieu chinois,
c'est un vrai combat à mort de gladiateurs.
Dans un milieu si dur, les entrepreneurs apprennent à grandir très rapidement,
ils apprennent à améliorer leurs produits à la vitesse de l'éclair,
et apprennent à parfaire leurs business models
jusqu'à ce qu'ils deviennent inattaquables.
Et par conséquent, les grands produits chinois comme WeChat et Weibo
sont sans doute meilleurs
que leurs équivalents américains, Facebook et Twitter.
Le marché chinois embrasse ce changement,
son accélération et les changements de paradigme.
Par exemple, si l'un d'entre vous va en Chine,
vous allez voir que les paiements se font presque sans espèces ni carte de crédit,
parce que cette chose dont on parle tous, le paiement par téléphone,
est devenue une réalité en Chine.
L'année dernière,
18,800 milliards de dollars américains ont été échangés via l'internet mobile,
et cela grâce à des technologies très robustes
qui le soutiennent.
C'est même une somme plus importante que le PIB chinois.
Et cette technologie, comment peut-elle être supérieure au PIB ?
Parce qu'elle comprend toutes les transactions :
Vente en gros, par filière, au détail, en ligne, hors ligne,
dans un centre commercial ou dans un marché agricole comme celui-ci.
Cette technologie est utilisée par 700 millions d'individus
pour payer tout le monde, pas seulement les marchants,
c'est donc du « peer to peer, »
c'est quasiment sans frais de transaction,
c'est instantané,
et utilisé partout.
Enfin, le marché chinois est gigantesque.
Le marché est considérable,
ce qui permet aux entrepreneurs d'avoir plus d'utilisateurs, plus de revenus,
plus d'investissements, mais surtout,
ça donne aux entrepreneurs l'occasion de récolter une énorme quantité de données
qui sont la nourriture du cerveau qu'est l'intelligence artificielle.
En conséquence, les entreprises chinoises d'IA
ont fait un bon en avant tel
que les entreprises de plus grande valeur
en vision artificielle, reconnaissance vocale,
synthèse vocale, traduction artificielle et en drones
sont toutes des entreprises chinoises.
Donc, avec les USA en pointe dans le domaines des découvertes
et la Chine qui mène dans le domaine de mise en œuvre,
nous arrivons maintenant dans une ère fantastique
où les deux moteurs de deux superpuissances
marchent de concert
pour conduire la plus rapide révolution technologique
que nous ayons vu en tant qu'humains.
Et cela va amener une richesse incroyable et sans précédent :
16.000 milliards de dollars, d'après PwC,
en termes de PIB additionnel pour le PIB mondial de 2030.
Cela apporte également d'immenses défis
en termes de remplacement d'emplois.
Alors que la révolution industrielle
a crée davantage d'emplois
car le travail artisanal a été décomposé en emplois sur des chaînes d'assemblage,
donc plus d'emplois étaient créés.
Mais l'IA remplace complètement les emplois individuels
de la chaîne d'assemblage avec des robots.
Et ce ne sont pas que les usines,
mais aussi les routiers, les conducteurs
et même des emplois comme la télévente, le service client
et les hématologistes, aussi bien que les radiologues
qui vont être progressivement remplacés
sur les 15 prochaines années
par l'intelligence artificielle.
Seuls les job créatifs --
(Rires)
Je dois me protéger, n'est ce pas ?
Réellement, les emplois créatifs sont ceux qui sont préservés,
car l'IA peut optimiser mais pas créer.
Mais ce qui est plus grave que la perte d'emplois
c'est la perte de sens.
Car l'éthique du travail dans l'ère industrielle
nous a fait croire que le travail était notre raison d'exister,
que c'est le travail qui donnait du sens à nos vies.
Et j'ai été une victime consentante de ce raisonnement type des accros au travail.
J'ai travaillé si dur.
C'est pourquoi j'ai faillit abandonner ma femme en salle d'accouchement,
c'est pourquoi je travaillais en 996 aux côtés de mes entrepreneurs.
Et cette obsession que j'avais avec le travail
s'est terminée brusquement il y a quelques années
quand on m'a diagnostiqué avec un lymphome au stade 4.
Ce PETscan montre plus 20 tumeurs malignes
qui sautent comme des boules de feu,
réduisant à néant mes ambitions.
Mais plus important,
cela m'a aidé à prendre du recul sur ma vie.
Savoir que je n'avais peut être plus que quelques mois à vivre
m'a montré la folie
de fonder mon entière confiance en moi
sur combien dur je travaillais et sur les résultat d'un travail acharné.
Mes priorités était complètement décalées.
Je négligeais ma famille.
Mon père était mort,
et je n'avais jamais pris le temps de lui dire que je l'aimais.
Ma mère était sénile et ne me reconnaissait plus,
et mes enfants avaient grandi.
Pendant ma chimiothérapie,
j'ai lu un livre de Bronnie Ware
qui parlait des souhaits et des regrets des gens sur leur lit de mort.
Elle avait vu que face à la mort,
personne ne regrettait de n'avoir pas travaillé suffisamment dur dans leur vie.
Ils regrettaient seulement de n'avoir pas passé assez de temps avec les êtres chers
et de ne pas avoir donné leur amour.
Aujourd'hui je suis heureusement en rémission.
(Applaudissements)
Donc je peux être de retour à TED
pour partager avec vous mon changement d'habitude.
Maintenant, je ne travaille plus qu'en 965.
-- Parfois 996 mais normalement 965. --
J'ai déménagé pour me rapprocher de ma mère,
ma femme m'accompagne dans mes déplacements,
et quand mes enfants sont en vacances, s'ils ne viennent pas, je les rejoins.
Donc c'est une nouvelle forme de vie
qui m'aide à reconnaître
l'importance qu'a cet amour pour moi,
et avoir vu la mort en face m'a aidé à changer de vie,
mais cela m'a aussi aidé à voir
comment l'IA pouvait influencer l'humanité d'une nouvelle façon
et que le travail pouvait coexister avec l'humanité,
que réellement, l'IA va supprimer beaucoup d'emplois routiniers,
mais on n'est pas fait pour des jobs routiniers.
On existe pour l'amour.
Quand nous tenons notre nouveau-né,
l'amour au premier regard,
ou quand nous aidons une personne dans le besoin,
Les humains ont cette capacité unique à donner et recevoir de l'amour,
et c'est ce qui nous différencie de l'IA.
Quoique puisse dire la science fiction.
Je peux vous dire avec expérience que l'IA n'a pas d'amour.
Quand AlphaGo a battu le champion du monde Ke Jie,
pendant que Ke Jie pleurait et aimait le jeu de Go,
AlphaGo ne ressentait aucun bonheur d'avoir gagné
et certainement aucun désir d'embrasser un être aimé.
Donc comment nous différencions-nous
en tant qu'humains dans l'ère de l'IA ?
Nous avons parlé des axes de créativité,
et c'est certainement une possibilité,
et maintenant, introduisons un nouvel axe
que nous appelons la compassion, l'amour, l'empathie.
Ce sont des choses étrangères à l'IA.
Tandis que l'IA va remplacer les emplois routiniers,
Je me plais à penser que nous pouvons et devons créer des emplois de compassion.
Vous pourriez demander combien de tels emplois existent,
et je vous demanderais :
Ne pensez-vous pas que nous allons avoir besoin de beaucoup de travailleurs sociaux
pour nous aider à faire cette transition ?
Ne pensez-vous pas que nous avons besoin de beaucoup de soignants
pour donner plus d'attention médicale à plus de gens ?
Ne pensez-vous pas qu'on va avoir besoin de 10 fois plus d'enseignants
pour aider nos enfant à trouver leur voie
pour aller, vivre et devenir dans ce nouveau monde ?
Et qu'avec toute cette nouvelle richesse,
nous devrions non seulement transformer les travaux d'amour en carrières
mais faire en sorte que l'accompagnement des personnes âgées
ou que faire l'école à la maison deviennent également des carrières ?
(Applaudissements)
Ce graphique n'est surement pas parfait,
mais il montre quatre façons dont on peut travailler avec l'IA.
l'IA va faire disparaître les tâches routinières
et le temps passant, nous en seront reconnaissant.
L'IA va devenir un outil formidable pour les créatifs
et les scientifique, artistes, musiciens et écrivains
seront encore plus créatifs.
l'IA va travailler avec les humains comme un outil analytique
auquel les humains pourront ajouter de la chaleur
pour les métier nécessitant de la compassion.
Et nous pourrons toujours nous différencier
avec les métiers uniques
qui font appel à la compassion et à la créativité,
en s'appuyant sur l'irremplaçabilité de nos cerveaux et nos cœurs.
Ainsi, nous y sommes :
Le programme de coexistence des humains et de l'IA.
l'IA est un heureux hasard.
Elle est là pour nous libérer des taches routinières,
et elle est là pour nous rappeler ce qui fait de nous des hommes.
Alors choisissons d'accueillir l'IA et de nous aimer les uns les autres.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)